will any player ever match me
well he would have to be some sort of
freak
what huh
is this the moon
of course i'd win the space race welcome
to an arena not only of sight and sound
but of mine on one side fresh off his
100 point game
1962 wilt chamberlain
first is the greek freak himself 20 21
yanis after the combo wow was that a
wormhole god bless america man
so they had to get a guy from the future
to challenge me
and what's on pace to be this 100 point
record i have so many questions 20 000
well to the rack he throws it down
world is just too dominant you can't
stop the best scorer of all time
actually i think it's jordan for average
and kareem for total i don't care who
those suckers are i can play in any era
maybe we could update the court then oh
thank god
[Applause]
get this man some kick so he doesn't
look like a hipster oh you got
what the hell is this sorry sir
learning new things is odd you know each
american city has its own type of pizza
there's so many types my turn
oh baby he's too clean
[Applause]
i'm deliverable
a communist from one downtown what
collects the rebound now driving the
baseline and he slams it home game point
i am the best at everything oh foul went
to the line
it's my only weakness okay
the trick to foul shots is to take
forever you'll get it and we'll finally
play some d amazing black man oh sorry
foul again you got it this time y'all
just so humble god we all love him
humble being humble works
damn welcome shooting gravity style this
is cringe just take the l yeah he's no
hero of mine anymore
god i hope bill russell ain't watching
this
and wilke wins with what i think is a
career now 11 points it's hard for a man
like me to say this but thank you i will
never forget you no it was my pleasure
i'm talking to the shoes
yeah this is a fine match-up but what
about mj versus lebron
card here get your portal call oh ooh
get us some yo how much for a quark uh
billion paw sex this damn highway
robbery you know this is why people just
subscribe below and don't come to the
game trying to make a living buddy